la nouvelle proposition de loi sur la
sécurité globale examiné aujourd'hui par
la commission des lois de l'assemblée
provoque la polémique notamment avec
l'article controversé sur les vidéos des
forces de l'ordre
on la doit à un tandem de député la
république en marche aller-retour au et
jean-pierre fauvergue ancien patron du
raid
il ne s'agit pas d'un projet de loi du
gouvernement ce qui permet donc aux
textes d'éviter l'avis obligatoire du
conseil d'état c'est pratique mais qui
retrouve-t-on à la manoeuvre pour
présenter ce texte dans les médias
gérald darmanin
il défend dans une vidéo son projet
pardon le projet des parlementaires et
vise à renforcer les moyens des polices
municipales mais aussi nous assurer les
moyens les agents de sécurité privés et
de mieux contrôler les images des
caméras de vidéo protection mais aussi
de gros mieux encadrer mais 2k
l'encadrement par le temps puisqu'à ce
jour usage du drone de surveillance a
été interdit en mai 2020 par le conseil
d'état est en ligne de mire on détecte
le spectre de la reconnaissance faciale
l'association la quadrature du net s'est
aussitôt insurgée
que fait la cnil dans tout cela
absolument rien son silence est
assourdissant alors qu'en face la
majorité parlementaire veut donner un
large pouvoir à la police pour nous
surveiller avec ses drones comme en
témoigne la ppl sécurité globale sur
laquelle nous reviendrons
autre sujet brûlant la question des
vidéos d'interventions policières
reprenons l'article est puni d'un an
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros
d'amendé le fait de diffuser dans le but
qu'il soit porté atteinte à son
intégrité physique ou psychique l'image
du visage ou tout autre élément
d'identification d'un fonctionnaire de
la police nationale ou d'un militaire de
la gendarmerie nationale lorsqu'il agit
dans le cadre d'une opération de police
donc fini les live facebook les
couvertures médiatiques de manifestation
en direct par peur d'être attaqué en
justice par un policier reconnaissable
le porte parole d'attac les réseaux
sociaux interdire la diffusion d'image
de policiers c'est pour protéger les
policiers ou pour protéger l'impunité
des violences policières
la fille de cédric souvient mort à la
suite d'un plaquage au sol lors d'un
contrôle policier a également protesté
il faut réagir dans quelques jours je
serai privés de la liberté de diffuser
les images où l'on aperçoit la mise à
mort de mon défunt père mais le texte
aux allures de fourre-tout compile de
nombreuses doléances des saints
ycare reçu par gérald darmanin extension
du port d'armes en dehors du service
possibilité de travailler dans la
sécurité à la retraite
pas de remise de peine pour les auteurs
d' attaques visant les forces de l'ordre
pas vraiment de la sécurité globale
mais revenons sur l'intention les
pouvoirs des policiers municipaux seront
renforcées mettre des pv des sabots
contre les saisies remettre en cellule
de dégrisement
la police municipale va monter en
puissance mais problème
elle sera tributaire du budget du maire
qui peut être très faible et de sa
sensibilité politique
cette ppl prévoit aussi de renforcer les
pouvoirs des plus de 165 mille employés
de sociétés de sécurité privées mais
attendez les maires demandent des
renforts policiers pas des agents de
sécurité
même s'ils sont parfois commode pour
pallier les carences de l'état au bout
de la ppl une véritable américanisation
de la sécurité et non pas des pouvoirs
de police globaux et homogène était ce
vraiment ce qu'attendent les français
les députés pour la plupart de gauche
ont déjà dégainé 430 amendement pour
remanier le texte